let's get more now on one of our top
stories the united nations secretary
general antonio guterres has condemned
the shelling around a nuclear plant in
ukraine the zaparisia
power plant is the largest nuclear
facility in europe and both russia and
ukraine have blamed each other
for the shelling well joining me now is
the former president of ukraine petro
poroshenko thank you
for
coming on the program this evening let's
just start uh mr poroshenko with the
this shelling around the nuclear plant
uh who is responsible for this the
russians say the ukrainians are doing it
ukrainians say the russians are doing it
what can you tell us about this
please
never
listen what russian's saying
putin and don't trust putin don't trust
russia
we
definitely should understand
that
not only they think that ukraine is
extremely responsible
the russia invaded ukraine and with that
situation
the catastrophe on
the parisia nuclear power station would
be ten times more powerful than
uh chernobyl station and definitely that
would be suffered the whole europe and
the whole world
the parisian power station delivered 20
of the all energy
balance of ukraine
50 of the nuclear power station
output and with this situation
definitely i just want to remind you
that still ukrainian personnel
are there
and with that situation we propose that
this question should be immediately put
in the agenda of the security council of
the united nation and immediately make a
very special decision to
deploy united nation peacekeeping
operation on the parisian power plant
because that would be suffered the whole
europe whole world if it would be
catastrophe
do you honestly think i'm sorry to
interrupt but do you think the the
russians would accept
international peak peacekeepers it needs
for this to work for inspectors to go
and it needs a
a conflict-free zone doesn't it and do
you think that is at all possible
look i think that their whole world
should speak loudly and with the because
this uh situation is a threat to the
global security
and if russia do not expect absolutely
clear steps it would be independent from
ukraine
international peacekeepers who can
guarantee the security of the world this
is exactly why we create security
council of the united nations and if
russia do not accept that we need to
introduce new embargo new sanction and
russia understand only the language of
strength and the whole world should
demonstrate the unity solidarity and
strength
well look on the war more broadly mr
poroshenko it looks like russia
uh the word coming from moscow as they
want to announce the annexation of the
donbass in
september or in the autumn what would
how would ukraine react to that
i just want to remind you that this war
is already more than eight years
and in the year 2014 me as a
commander-in-chief of ukrainian supreme
commander-in-chief of ukrainian armed
forces and the president of ukraine in
the year 2014 release from russian
troops two-thirds of the occupied dombas
and create the new armed forces of
ukraine based on the nato standard
and with that situation now
the slavensk kramatorsk constantine
and significant part of the donbas under
control of ukrainian troops and just
last week i returned back from the zone
of the
russian military operation of on the
east of my country i visited the bahamut
the slavians cremator series and i just
want to tell you that ukrainian troops
is full of decisiveness and they are not
have any sign to readiness to
go back and the only thing they need
is oh three things this is the weapons
weapons and weapons and by the way
i
have the special request from the
soldiers that they want to thank the
british people the british
government british parliament and
british prime minister for
significant and new weapons we receive
and because of these weapons this is uh
uh demonstrate the effectiveness of
ukrainian armed forces and the point
number two this is absolutely
unacceptable
to create the precedent for the
future to
change the borders by force because if
we accept that
from russia now it would be no borders
uh with the
at all in europe and the next definitely
okay
let me just yeah sorry to interrupt you
again we're just short of time but is
your concern is your worry that
the west becomes or you know the eu and
the united states
nato becomes more divided over the
winter as the energy prices
bite and the energy shortages come in
how concerned are you that
the
the west becomes more divided over this
and ukraine loses that support or loses
some of that support
look i'm an optimist
and want to tell you that this is
impossible to be the
president on my position since year 2014
2019 of the country in a state of war
and not believe in our victory
and this is just a language of blackmail
by russia
please do not accept the language of
black mayor we are stronger
truth is with us democracies with us
freedom is with us and the only person
in the world who has a ukrainian fatigue
is mr putin
he is really fatigued and tired from
sanctions from embargo from uh
power from the world solidarity uh
against russia for ukraine for creating
anti-putin coalition for the isolation
and with that situation definitely
all the western leaders and all the
people of the
uh free world should understand that
this is not just an assistance of
ukraine this is investment in your own
security and just
help us to do your job help us to save
the world and with that situation please
keep in mind that every single day you
pay
pay
disastrous price for
uh
saving the world okay just one last
question
yeah just one last question uh mr
poroshenko
can the ukrainians retake
territory can they retake kessan for
instance in the in the south which is
very important controls the water supply
for crimea and so forth can the
ukrainians do that
undoubtedly
definitely yes
and you should understand that the only
thing we need for that
is
artillery
ammunition
anti-aircraft missiles
and the
jet fighter
and with that situation
if now we have a 10 times more russian
ammunition more russian
hobbits
russian cannon and russian flight and
even if it would be equal sites
ukrainian uh has significantly more
motivation but for the right bank of
nepal river on kerzown region definitely
i just returned from there and i know
that the counter-attack of ukrainian
troops counter-attack should happen in
august we have everything
but
uh artillery and ammunition and just
imagine that this is different type of
war
mankind never have this type of war when
this is not just a number of troops but
this is again
drones
artillery ammunition missiles
and with that situation we significantly
rising now this amount because of the
western supply and please don't have any
doubt that if we stop russian troops
without western weapons we can win
russia throw him away from ukraine with
the western weapons with the western
solidarity with the western support no
doubt okay
mr poroshenko appreciate your time
thanks for coming on